okay this is a candy crush soda saga
level 13 video um i'm gonna do some
commentary
and a little tutorial to help explain
how to
beat this level it's one of the first
ones that people get stuck on all the
time so
just going to talk about it real quick
the
color bomb that's trapped here is really
important as you can imagine and you
want to connect it with one of these two
stripes
so what we're going to try to do is
we're going to try to set off a striped
plus wrapped candy up here
or just a series of
you know striped candies to go down and
free two of these
so
even though we have 20 bears and we have
all this um
all these whipped cream cream squares
that we had to clear out
we're not going to worry about too much
other than just making striped candies
so
here you can see we have a gap where we
can maybe drop one down an orange one
down so i'm going to start out there
and um
we got an opportunity for wrapped or
straight i'm going to go ahead and make
the the wrapped because those are a
little bit harder to set up and now
we're going to try to
you know drop one of these red ones down
or
set up another one somewhere
um
a fish
a fish fish by themselves aren't that
great on this level but they are good
when you mix them with
the other candy so we're just going to
go ahead and do that
because that'll
make more room so we can make better
matches
of course you make a fish by making you
know for a square and they're really
helpful on soda bottle levels and stuff
like that but
on levels like this where you have a lot
of space to clear they're usually a lot
better if you or chocolate
the same
you're better off to
mix them with another special candy
all right so now we got another
wrapped so we're going to look for
a chance to make a striped
all right so there's our striped and our
wrapped i'm going to combine those
together and that's going to free these
two from their licorice
ropes or whatever you call those
all right so now we have um
there's not a lot of green ones up here
to set things in motion mostly most of
the time
you're going to want to definitely make
this match right away
because it's going to turn these as well
and it's going to basically open the
entire board for us
but
in this case i'm going to
just try to make a couple matches and
see if i can get
a couple more green candies to drop onto
the board
there's a couple more i don't want to
mess around with it beyond that but
that's two more you know stripes that
are going to be going around the board
and
i guess you'd go ahead and fire that one
off too and make those
but we'll just leave those where they
are and um they'll get fired off by a
green one
all right so you can see how that how
effective that is i mean that opened up
most of the board we can see where most
of the bears are now
and um
now we still have 36 moves left and
we have way less work to do than we did
just a little bit ago
so
again you know you can see a lot of
opportunities to make fish here but
those aren't
as important as setting up some bigger
matches
so you know just use your discretion
like here i can set up a stripe so i'm
going to do that instead
you know i'll make use of fish and make
a stripe
and
just you know
just be careful as you're making your
matches try not to miss anything
uh for here like when you're when you're
working directly around getting the
bears with a lot of moves you don't have
to be too
worried but what i would do is make your
matches at the bottom
and then um
you know just check up top from time to
time but actually after each match to
make sure that you're not missing an
opportunity to make a big one up there
like a
a color bomb or a
i've always called them bubble bombs but
i guess the official name for them is
the coloring candy the um
the one that looks like
it's trapped inside of a bubble
this is going to
set off
oh no it's not going to be all right
and you see why that's so important to
use your color bomb and the stripe
together because you get cascades
otherwise you you're basically just
making a series of matches and it's
really hard to work your way down the
board if you're watching this video
that's probably what you found out so
um stripes and fish are good because
it's going to shoot a i mean they picked
the worst
one and it does that sometimes but
other times you'll get a better match
out of it
i'm going to waste this one over here
but i'm going to try to bring these two
together because that'll pretty much
open things up some more
and we're up to 15 so we have one over
here a couple here there's one hidden
behind there that means
so that's going to be the hardest one to
get the ones on the side are definitely
harder
but with 20 moves i'm not
that concerned yet
all right so now we have a spot here
where we can make a a color bomb
if we can get the right color to drop
there's no oranges above there at all
though so
just kind of keep that in mind if we can
move this one over that would be good
i just went ahead and got rid of it
because i'm concerned about these
and since we don't we're down just a few
blocks fish now are worth they're more
important because they'll actually you
know eat at the ice that we're trying to
get rid of
and that you can see why the ones on the
side are hard to get because they just
don't
it's harder to set up matches above them
so i get 11 moves what i'm going to do
is just um
look to make some fish
and
see if i have any other big matches pop
up along the way
um matching two fish together is really
good too because
the two fish turn into three fish and
that take out three squares
so you see i got rid of
two of my bears
right there
all right so
there's the fish
at this point if we can get
just that one fish to go then everything
will be good and instead we'll get a
bonus
and when you match a color bomb with a
fish it'll turn all the red ones into
fish which will
finish the level
all right so that's how you do it um
take a second to like this video if you
found it helpful
definitely if you have any questions
about this game or how it works leave a
comment
visit our website candy crush soda saga
tips for more info like this and
we'll be making more videos soon thanks